il pellet di ragazzi e berni che questo
appello a tutti ragazzi ebbene quella
fisica si è rotto il cazzo acli
coincidenza che proprio non mi metto a
registrare forni lavori nelle altre case
fantastico bella tutti ragazzi e ben
tenuti a questo video sono fa dj e non
ci siamo il nuovo blog
non so più parlare campo incomincia
ragazzi come al solito di iniziare con
la parata della settimana che questa
settimana è stata vinta da da un maschio
da un maschio ragazzi incredibile stata
vinta da simone che ha fatto sto disegno
della madonna che non lo saprei fare
nemmeno se mi date 75 anni di di tempo
ogni tanto sapere che anche dei ragazzi
sono di segnale di segnale cazzola
graziosi non so parlare avete pazienza
sapere che anche i ragazzi sono
disegnare recentemente un sollievo
diciamo lunga piacere che possiamo
passare alle news anche se madonna matt
inquietante st manica che spunta nel
video con che i ragazzi passando alle
news siamo arrivati ad oltre 900 mila
iscritti certo riesci siamo arrivati già
dallo scorso blog però nello stesso
luogo aperti fatti non potevo dirvelo
come se nome l'avresti ha fatto notare
comunque siamo arrivati al 900 mila
iscritti ragazzi che siete con me
non so perché sto facendo così comunque
ragazzi grazie di cuore per il traguardo
fantastico
tutti ragazzi siccome filmetto finito
l'esame è aumentato la frequenza di
video ovviamente capiterà che magari un
giorno non lo so per qualche motivo
magari dovevo pagare dalla mattina alla
sera
non lo so comunque potrebbe capitare
anche magari che un giorno non carico
invito sono un essere umano sempre c'è
quello non scordatevelo però comunque
visto che ho finito gli esami mediamente
un video al giorno uscirà sempre ragazzi
spero siate contenti detto queste
ragazzine ripassa passare allo sport
allo sparta gio
prende oggi si che possiamo passare allo
scartato dei pacchi perfetto siccome
ragazzi nonostante il blog che ho fatto
l'ultima volta che ne ho avuti tipo una
trentina che bacini attorno ragazzi la
sono ancora pieno zeppo di pacchi da
aprire quindi prima o poi dovrò fare un
secondo blog dovrei apro tutti e per
oggi ragazzi ha deciso di aprirne 4
tanto c'è un pacco che bellissimo che è
questo ciao ragazzi io non lo so pensare
di moschino che si è consegnato sta cosa
avesse visto sto cazzo che cosa potrebbe
aver mai pensato ma noi dei ragazzi ma
20 scaldano subito perché sono troppo
curioso di vedere cos'è l'erboristeria
che se ci ha messo va dentro la
marijuana già paura ad aprirla ragazzi
ma non importa
ma regalò io giuro puro cioè non ho mai
visto una cosa più filgia di questa mi
avete inviato un troll face siete due
zeri cazzo fatta con un troll face e
bellissimi ci sono mica che figo
credo che siano gli occhiali più ghanzi
che abbia mai indossato in vitamine la
fa venute 976 fatta benissimo si tuffa
vj bale meglio di così non l'ho mai
vista da c'è questi tre ingredienti non
ci sono di sei già a memoria è ovvio che
so di che cosa è fatta la nutella ce la
faccio io praticamente
[Musica]
ed infine ragazzi c'è questo cartoncino
che credo sia una panart quasi
sicuramente lui che fa vigenti world
dance è fantastica che ancora non mi sa
che mi sa che riceverà delle sorpresine
c'è scritto qui passato al prossimo
ragazzi che anche dato il tutto rosso mi
sembra di essere al natale ci sono delle
cuffie nuove ma mi sa che mi stanno
queste mi stanno invece fantastico
ragazzi c'è uno che cazzo è sto coso
e infine ragazzi c'è la mia finta carta
d'identità che è fantastica sentito dato
la mia foto sulla carta d'identità è
qualcosa di spettacolare è bellissimo
prestito non è fa vj cognome youtuber
età infinita nato l'anno zero e vedete
adesso siamo nell'anno 2014 avanti fa
vigente per l'impronta del sindaco sulla
carta d'identità che mi sembra cioè o il
sindaco e iron man oppure cia dei
problemi attuali pastrello del prossimo
parecchi ragazzi venuti in casa è sta
roba
c'è un paio di jeans che però mi
sembrano leggermente sono magro pro
cazzo mi sono un po stretti dopo li
provo un ciondolo di angry birds un
cappello di babbo natale grazie
così ha molto più stile altri turati ma
perchè continuate inviarmi trucchi lega
ma che cazzo vabbè grazie comunque una
fan otto ragazzi che è fantastica e fas
e tanto riesco a ricrearla nella vita
reale aspettare un attimo io non vorrei
dire produce che la vedova iniziare a
fare l'artista perché c'è volete mettere
cazzo dead space extraction per nintendo
wii
c'è anche chi cm menu octopus con coca
cola a 5 euro fantastico e come ultimo
ragazzi una voglia che ho scritto keep
calm and love that mario è una cosa
fantastica però non credo di prenderla
alla lettera è detto questo ragazzino
che possiamo passare al tro il face
risponde la prima domanda arriva da
kleber juice fa risponde a famiglia
perché non ti fai twitter di questa
risposta dovevo darvi assolutamente
perché molti me lo chiedono la ragazza
in verità io non ho twitter perché non
ancora capito bene come si usa acuita
scrive non ha mai capito per bene come
si usa ho deciso di farmi facebook è
instagram che sono i miei unici due
società ovviamente oltre a youtube ma
ormai ragazzi anche se tentò di farlo
credo che per ambiente non possa più
comunque perché mi sa che mi ha [ __ ]
tutti i nickname possibili tipo fa
vigenti buffa vj favi già iscritto gola
gino vige scritto col nome di mia nonna
favi già iscritto al contrario quindi
credo che non possa comunque più farmelo
fab four a bud fox
poi risponde favi che giochi usavi con
tuo padre da bambini giocherò ma spesso
tipo a pro evolution soccer che mi
massacrava tipo mio quaderno giocavamo a
calcio insieme sulla play sono ancora
tantissimo con lui perché mica non ne
faceva vincere una maledizione nostro
gioco invece era budokai tenkaichi
invece mi calo e li davo mazzate quanto
bastava malak bit mangia che non so
parlare oggi porca [ __ ] dei nuovi
facili da pronunciare non risponde
perchè non fai un video
in cui apre tutti i commenti che non so
come fare ad aprire ad aprire tutti i
commenti ma nel tuo caso ne apro
soltanto uno ok tu adesso ho aperto per
gli altri sono un po tanti però va bene
a cosa ragazzi scusate vi sono sono
riuscito a fare scenette stavolta nel
blog perché già tardissimo e se non
iniziate vittoria del sorbito mista che
stanotte non vado a dormire questi
ragazzi se il video vi è piaciuto come
al solito è sotto un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come non
divida tratta una descrizione aires e
vorresti scheletri che ci vediamo al
prossimo vinto bene ragazzi